every gambler knows when you play at the
casino - the odds aren't in your favor
the house always wins
rules are set in stone if you play the
big six wheel that wheel that we always
stick right in the front of the casino
you don't have much of a chance Jim
Warren is CEO of MGM which owns a third
of the casinos on the Vegas strip let's
say you're gonna spend about a thousand
dollars theoretically
we're going to win $200 from you about
20% of the money you use circulate so on
average you'll lose 20% of the money you
play but what if you could change the
rules and twist the on don't negotiate
for high-end players if you're playing
picking up Don Johnson is a blackjack
player who won fifteen million dollars
in Atlantic City in a single winning
streak I beat him beg you beat him
because he's an industry insider who
knows exactly what to negotiate before
he steps in a casino for starters he
wants big bet they were letting me play
twenty five thousand a hand by three
hands 275 thousand a swing at
seventy-five thousand a swing it's not
that hard to win four million dollars
but not that our four million dollars I
didn't have four million to lose that
was the team he negotiates himself a
discount a twenty percent rebate on all
of his losses and once done secured
those advantages in discounts he turns
his attention to the rules of the game
so walk me through the rules that they
gave you that were so advantageous to
you standing on soft seventeen
if a dealer gets an 86 the dealer has to
stand on that hand instead of taking
another card doubling on any two cards
doubling your back yes some places have
rules that won't allow you to do that
splitting hands up to four hands even
with his rooms the 20% discount and the
big bets down negotiated the house still
had a tiny advantage there is a house
edge built into it about 0.25 three
tenths of a percent
not satisfied with those odds DOM
figured out how to tip the game in his
favor you need to be better than the
dealer because if you can beat the
dealer you can beat the house there
aren't enough players that come in that
they're gonna deal a hundred thousand a
hand too they're nervous can you
encourage them to make the fake and
intimidate them or distract them and all
kinds of distractions for dealers have
pornstars play with me I've had you know
five six seven eight different girls at
the toes as a girlfriend
this is attractive dealer of course does
it work yeah there's always a circus
going on to their money the more it
looks like one giant party the better it
is for my side of the table if there's a
distraction they make a mistake what's
the worst thing that can happen I get a
free bet and you know immediately when
they've made a mistake I think I've
caught every mistake that they've made
that was not in my favor and made them
give me the free pet because those are
the rules of the game it's how
ultimately Don Johnson took on the
casino industry in Atlantic City
115 million dollars he became the
legendary gambler who beat the house